STARTED TODAY.
CORRESPONDENT PETER DOOCY IS IN
THE "SHOW ME" STATE TO SHOW YOU.
>> JOSH HOLLY IS A TOP
REPUBLICAN RECRUIT TRYING TO
UNSEAT ONE OF THE DEMOCRATS
HOPING TO WIN REELECTION IN A
STATE PRESIDENT TRUMP WON,
MISSOURI.
>> CLAIRE McCASKILL HAS TO GO.
>> TRUMP BEAT CLINTON BY A
WHOPPING 19 POINTS AND TOMORROW
ONE DAY AFTER THE 38-YEAR-OLD
ATTORNEY GENERAL HOLLY STARTED
CAMPAIGNING, PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
FLYING IN TO RAISE MONEY FOR
HIM.
>> I LOOK FORWARD -- HOPEFULLY
HE WILL BE HERE FREQUENTLY.
>> IN 2012 McCASKILL WON
EASILY BECAUSE HER OPPONENT WAS
CAUGHT UP IN CONTROVERSY OVER
COMMENTS ABOUT "LEGITIMATE RAPE
RAPE."
>> WE ARE GOING TO TAKE IT
SERIOUSLY.
>> DEMOCRATS THINK A SCANDAL AT
THE STATEHOUSE WILL HELP THEM.
THE GOVERNOR WAS RECENTLY
INDICTED ON FELONY INVASION OF
PRIVACY CHARGES STEMMING FROM AN
EXTRAMARITAL AFFAIR.
>> ERIC GREITENS HAS PUT HIMSELF
FIRST OVER PARTY, CITIZENS.
>> HOLLY DOESN'T SEE THE
GOVERNOR DRAGGING HIM DOWN.
>> THE SITUATION IS NOT GOOD FOR
THE STATE.
THAT'S WHAT CONCERNS ME.
>> HOLLY HINTED McCASKILL
HINDERING THE PRESIDENT'S AGENDA
IS WHAT THIS WILL HINGE ON.
>> SHE VOTED NO ON TAX RELIEF
FOR AMERICAN FAMILIES.
SHE VOTED NO JUSTICE GORSUCH.
SHE VOTED SHE VOTED
NONREGULATORY ROLLBACK.
SHE HAS VOTED AGAINST THE
INTERESTS OF MISSOURI AND WITH
HER PARTY.
THAT'S WHY SHE'S GOING TO LOSE.
>> THE WAY HOLLY SEES IT YOU'RE
EITHER HELPING PRESIDENT TRUMP
OR YOU ARE NOT.
THAT'S HOW HE'S BEEN SHAPING
THIS RACE.
WE FOLLOWED HIM ON HIS BUS